And, yes, I don't have trust in this.
The reason is from a 2100 square foot home that's clearly small than this one
the price has decreased. It'd gone down.
Do we believe that in general between a 2100 square foot home and a 2300 square foot home
the price should go down?
Do we actually believe that in a scatter plot like this the functional relationship between
size and cost goes like this?
Or do we instead believe it should go like this?
The deviations from that linear graph is what's  called "noise."
Now, noise might not be the best term, but it's the term that statisticians use.
It might be that one of them has a great view.
The next one has an old house.
This one has coastal access, which makes it more expensive.
This one really requires a new kitchen.
There might be factors that really effect the house price beyond the size.
But if those factors are unincluded, to a statistician that's called "random noise."
But coming back to my original question, I think we don't believe the red curve.
Let's  talk about bar charts as one way to alleviate the problem.